what he said to people
that describe Israel as having a
historical right to the land
so if you stretch not across decades but
across centuries into the past
this kind of thing is a red herring um
it's a destruction because you don't
think of any state
as having rights but there is this
exceptionalism to the Israeli regime
where it is it has a right to defend
itself and it has a right to the land
and it has a right to shoot 14 year old
boys because
it thought they had a knife in their
pockets you know a lot of the time
people cite the Torah on site religious
books and you know sometimes zionists
will even say like read the Quran and
blah blah blah you know regardless of
whatever was written in these books that
were written thousands and thousands of
years ago the fact of the matter is no
one has a right to go on slaughtering
people removing them from their homes
and then continuing to live in their
homes continuing to drink coffee on
their balconies
um decades and decades later with no
shame with no introspection
with no reflection that's no one has the
right to do that no one has the right to
keep an entire population of people in a
cage
uh which is what's happening to people
in the West Bank who have no freedom of
of movement which is what's happening
in Gaza which is blockaded
to water air and land and
is deemed uninhabitable by human rights
organizations like the UN
um no one has a right to do that